hey guys it's a new week and that means
it's time for new releases and even if
you're not done with uncharted 4 or doom
I still have to do this show so we're
going to do it anyway so let's get
started first up shadow of the beast
this will kind of snuck up on me it's
like a remake reimagining of the 1989
game with the same name it was made
famous on Commodore Amiga the game
follows the story of the original
predecessor so again you are the same
character you were kidnapped as a child
your corrupted through magic and your
kind of turned into a warrior servant
but now you're self-aware and you're out
for blood you have a traditional health
bar in combos through quick time events
and traps and you can get those original
jet engines all taking place inside
dungeons graphics in this version will
appear to keep same parallax scrolling
from the original title but it's in 3d
you can unleash this beast on the 17
next up is homefront the revolution
which takes place in the future 2029 in
an alternate timeline in an open world
with many districts to explore your
following Ethan Brady is he fights
against North Korea's invasion of
paddy's pub in the city of Philadelphia
your scavenging parts from buildings and
stashes to create and modify weapons and
equipment there's a new enhanced ability
to modify weapons such as adding a
foregrip or site in the middle of a
firefight or to convert a rifle into a
light machine gun and vice versa you
start that rebellion on the 17th chadwin
is a stealth action game where the only
rule is to remain unseen we got this
dumb kid hanging around killing your
style you sneak and explore around the
dark and greedy medieval province using
the environment to your advantage you
know to like kill people use the ropes
to grapple on rooftops silently dropped
from ceilings you can veil yourself in
the shadows time stands still when
you're not moving allowing you to stop
at any point mid motion so you can like
ruwan
time if you can do that there's honestly
no excuse for you to not succeed in this
game you just keep rewinding unless
you're bored then you don't have to
start sneak in on the 17th valkyria
chronicles comes back from past this
original 2008 release is now remastered
and coming to ps4 the game is set in
fictional Europa loosely based on yep
you guessed it Europe during the early
years of World War two because of its
abundance of rag night or which is like
their oil in the game setting the
neutral nation of Gallia comes under
attack from the east european imperial
alliance wars for oil that's crazy this
is a tactical role-playing game in which
the player uses unique turn-based battle
system called blitz which stands for
battle of vlad tactical zone got lots of
characters to choose from alysha is a
mid range rifle toting scout while
welkin is a tank commander other roles
include shocktroopers Lancers snipers
and engineers giving you that sweet rock
paper scissor style strategic gameplay
grab that sweet sweet rag night on 17th
finally duskers is coming out of early
access this wednesday you're piloting
drones into derelict ships to find
goodies like turrets and fuel but
there's something else in those ships
bad stuff and it totally wants to kill
you you got to figure out how to take
care of these horrible monsters by
sucking them out into space or killing
them with your turrets but everything
goes wrong on these ships and it's your
job basically find a way to survive it's
pretty intense and there's no worse
feeling than losing a drone no uh
protect your drones on the 18th so
that's it for this week remember that
release dates are based on retailer
listings and sometimes we change see you
next week